ja es ist manchmal Scheiße du hast
recht Christopher verstehen wir auch so
wer sich denn eigentlich so Klein sind
dass es keinen Sinn wenn man so will
ich habe immer so hart ist es mich denke
es kommen lamentieren und Leiharbeit
ein anderer um sie zum Kaffe trinken
Forssell keine
kein Wort September an
da es geht nicht immer nur darum einfach
gut auszusehen oder so
ist doch nicht jeder Punkt klar bei
allen nicht nur
wenn man einmal den die Lust gefunden
hat
um einfach mal zu fahren merkt dass er
wie auch weil es Spaß macht
dann geht das auch immer von selber
ziemlich Kohl macht jetzt mal
als Sport ist in mein Leben integriert
mal mehr oder mal weniger
also werden gut Begriff Fitness Buch
passt das schon ganz gut es geht um
Ernährung also alle einig alles was man
sich so was an Spartans ein Vergleich
bei dem Begriff
es gibt natürlich auch darum
wenn man eigentlich faules und gar
keinen Bock hat was man machen kann um
sich zu motivieren
ich wollte mein Freund ist warnt
installiert
ich bin mir ganz sicher dass ich mich
gar nicht in seinem Waschbrettbauch
verliebt aber sonst
wenn ich mit dem Lauf Vergangenheit ja
eine halbe Stunde lang nicht an
also laufen immer so dass man auch ein
bisschen albern sein kann dass man sich
schützen kann der Bayern über die
dummen Sprüche machen kann Bianca
ich habe dann vorab gesagt haben ich
werde nicht gehen willst also dann
verschlechtert
als ihr momentaner damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun weil sie mir andere Sachen
gibt
in haben uns ja schon mal ein konkreter
damit befasst
und sen der Mann aufgegeben weil es so
kompliziert war
wer's Amerikaner also da gibt es ja den
Familien mehr über den Atlantik und wo
macht man das jetzt sind wir alle sehr
man das
Zhang war einfach auch mit Hilfe eines
über den kleiner ist einfach nicht
hingekriegt
ich hoffe dass das dieses Jahr noch
hinkriegt
alles ist ganz einfach hat lernten
einfacher vorgestellt